I really love this place Good Vibes the
cello May complex was built from the
ground up to be the ideal comfortable
workplace atomic heart doesn't hide its
BioShock Infinite Inspirations the game
begins in a city in the clouds features
reality bending and elemental powers you
can employ in your fight against
Advanced robots sees you scrounging for
resources in idyllic City that's falling
apart and stars in amnesiac protagonist
grappling with the nuances of Free Will
by the time you reach the climax of the
story and you're asked to visit a
lighthouse you know what's up we're
atomic heart most differs from its
inspiration as in the lens through which
it focuses its narrative exploring
concepts of Free Will via Soviet Russian
collectivism instead of the us as
individualism however its intriguing
premise is let down by a deeply
unlikable protagonist and a predictable
storyline that doesn't do anything
interesting with its cool ideas
in the alternate history of atomic heart
a scientist kick-starts a robotics boom
in Russia in the 1930s by the 1950s the
working class has been abolished in the
Soviet Union and completely replaced by
robots controlled through a hive mind
Network known as collective 1.0 the game
begins a few years after that just prior
to the public unveiling of collective
2.0 which will allow all humans to have
equal access to the hive mind to control
robots remotely through a thought device
wired straight to their brain as well as
connect and share information with each
other across great distances basically
it's the internet plugged into your
brain and available 24 7. with the
benefit of 21st century hindsight we
know the internet will not end up being
a 100 good idea even if the main
character Sergey AKA agent P3 fully
believes in the dream of a world where
everyone equally has access to each
other and the wealth of information that
will surely be shared assigned to
investigate a disturbance in facility
3826 the Soviet Union's foremost
scientific research Hub Sergey is joined
by Charles a sentient glove that gifts
the agent with a host of polymer fed
techno powers like telekinesis and
cryokinesis and provides a sounding
board for sergey's oftentimes annoying
and borderline abusive collection of
quips and unfunny comebacks we need to
find a way to open this armored door gee
you think enough with the lame advice
will ya within the now blood-soaked
hallways and flickering lights of the
partially destroyed underground facility
Sergey discovers experiments into
mutation gone awry and finds that the
once peaceful robot assistance have
turned bloodthirsty the true horror
doesn't come until later however when
Charles talks to Sergey about the ways
in which collectors 2.0 which is already
installed into Sergey may not be
entirely beneficial hasn't Sergey
noticed that all those audio logs he's
found in computers he's logged into only
give him information that's relevant to
furthering the mission he's been
assigned wow it's almost as if the
algorithm is feeding him with
information about what it thinks he
should see and hear more of disguising
it in a way where he can't spot the
manipulation it's not as overt a form of
control as a spoken command but Charles
hence that humans can be directed just
as easily as robots once they've all
logged into the same hive mind of
information especially if there is a way
to control that information it's an
intriguing concept one furthered by the
notion that atomic heart is a video game
and so we the player have been directing
sergey's actions the entire time so it's
not just Sergey who's being manipulated
to view the game's World in a certain
way based on a fictional internet
algorithm it's us too but as interesting
as it is exploring Free Will through the
scope of a video game story has been
done before and atomic heart doesn't do
anything notably novel with the concept
in fact its protagonist actively gets in
the way of this concept being explored
raging at Charles that he doesn't have
time to wax poetic about hypotheticals
he can't be bothered to offer any sort
of introspection because there are
robots that need to be stopped and a bad
guy to blame that needs killing over and
over Charles brings up the morality of
their mission and the larger
implications of what's going on and
repeatedly Sergey just doesn't care
citing that he'll leave the thinking to
the bosses the first and second time it
happens you're hopeful that this flaw is
setting up some form of character
development for Sergey when you're 10
hours in and Sergey is still spinning in
the same pattern and showing no signs of
growing as a person you can't help but
wonder how anyone could be this
stubbornly bone-headed and annoyingly
naive you can really tell we're on a
threshold of something really incredible
Sergey is also deeply unlikable as a
person he's antagonistic to everyone
around him including the regularly
helpful Charles and it's never explained
why leading to the slow realization of
the painful truth that you're just
playing as a shitty human being you
don't feel good playing as Sergey
whenever he opens his mouth to talk to
anyone I empathize more with the people
who have to tolerate his barrage of
unfunny insults than I do him obviously
the last canister has to be lodged deep
in the universe's Quantum [__]
stuff happened to everyone it was just
me despite being a jerk he does know how
to fight wielding polymer abilities with
his left hand and an assortment of
firearms and weapons with his right
Sergey is a hard-hitting fighter while
the robots and mutants he goes up
against are far faster than he is you
can easily escape the Swarms by using
sergey's Dash to reposition curating a
frenetic hit and run combat experience
though relatively simple at first combat
evolves into a more engaging experience
as more enemy types are introduced each
with its own attack patterns and
weaknesses atomic heart has a healthy
diversity of enemy types however there's
nothing you'll face you probably haven't
fought a variation of before in other
games ranging from dog-like enemies that
try to Circle you before pouncing your
direction to turret-like adversaries
that shoot at you from afar to Bulky
foes who heavily Telegraph their attacks
but can take a hit the same goes for the
weapons and Powers he used to fight them
the pump action shotgun hits like you
expect a shotgun should for instance and
the cold polymer power freezes enemies
in their tracks just as you'd assume
there's no nothing revolutionary to how
combat plays out but it all works as it
should it's familiar but still fun
looting is surprisingly the most
enjoyable aspect of atomic heart as with
just the click of a button Charles can
use telekinesis to pull loot into
sergey's pocket in practice this causes
drawers to fly open cabinet doors to
almost swing off their hinges and the
bodies of enemies to erupt as the
magnetic pull of Charles rips the
resources of room towards Sergey it
never got old to enter in an unexplored
room or clear out a group of enemies and
then sit back to watch as everything
around me exploded into a whirlwind of
paper and scraps of metal sucked into my
coffers like a greedy tornado of course
you can then use these resources to
craft new Firearms ammo weapon
attachments and items but the sheer
Delight of the ACT is almost enough of a
reward in and of itself after completing
the first mission Sergey takes a
monorail to the main area of the game
where atomic heart expands into an open
world format at this point the game's
narrative slows to an annoying crawl as
Sergey Journeys to one of several
facilities to complete a mission return
to the surface of the open world travel
to the next facility and repeat the
process even if you don't take the time
to freely explore the map complete
optional challenges and look for
materials to unlock special attachments
for your Firearms the journey between
waypoints still bogs down the story
nothing of narrative importance happens
outside of the contained linear levels
of the different facilities and combat
benefits from the carefully structured
layout of those contained levels even
enemy placement and type are curated to
fit specific areas of the linear levels
and that careful curation is lost within
the breadth of the open world I would
often just hop in a car and drive
straight to the next story beat as
that's where the better gameplay is it
makes the open world feel Superfluous
adding content at the expense of
enjoyability fortunately some of the
main levels have a distinct flavor and
engaging themes to them helping them to
stand out against the largely
forgettable open world as atomic heart
has a great soundtrack filled with
thumping high energy music from Doom
composer Mick Gordon that will get your
head bobbing during even the most butt
clenching of battles
foreign
but these powerful rhythms are usually
reserved for Boss encounters meaning a
lot of the game's best music is fleeting
and only pops up for one encounter
before never being heard from again in
fact there are quite a few instances
where the powerful soundtrack feels
wasted because the superb composition
that's playing doesn't match the vibe of
what you're currently doing
there are quite a few parts of atomic
heart that just don't neatly fit
together and those disparities create an
experience that often feels at odds with
itself that disparity is most evident in
how the history of the world in atomic
heart is interesting it sets up an
intriguing conversation about the nature
of Free Will and collectivism but then
the unlikable protagonist repeatedly
prevents that topic from being explored
tomicart is certainly going to appeal to
some people especially those looking to
relive BioShock Infinite but it's not an
easy recommendation
without a civilian robot for real that
thing a civilian robot you tell me major
you have far more experience with combat
robots than I do I I do I mean
[__] I do but I can't remember a damn
thing they seem different somehow